I think first there's as many issues
feet retina is facing and there's very
complicated and by survive to try to
surviving in the competition they
sacrificed a lot of Rights which also
nobody the environment and this also
sacrifice education and the whole
society become extremely corrupted and
also extremely incapable make clear
decisions under the judicial system also
paralyzed but about the environment I
think which certainly relate to
everybody's life yet if you talk one
name and nature and the natural
environment it's about air water and
food safety and all those concerns which
today is a great trouble for China you
know we find poisoning almost everything
you know
rivers polluted all the safer apology
milk included or meet her polluted or
vegetables are followed by back almost
every choice what they come to a table
they always have something in the
Mounties you know what they're eating
it's suitable for the body or its
dangers for their children which which
you become such a concern nobody can
void so you can see the change of
society really come from those concerns
which involves everybody doesn't doesn't
matter your political standard or you
know what and ideology you have for your
your periodic or you're just activists
but still you know the the safety and
the well-being of daily life and also
about the concern of environment are
really a major concern of China today
first for any society not to mention
China has such a large and complicated
conditions and the lobby she for any
society to survive you have to have a
sense of justice and fairness and this
is a its property of the public and
that people should believe there's
justice justice exists in this society
under that can be achieved through the
struggle so certainly China doesn't have
an independent judicial system so for a
long time this can't justice never
exists that's a really a problem so
because it ever it doesn't exist so
people has no trust the penny kind of
policy and any kind of news or media
because there is no freedom of
expression and so how can you have a
society working together or try to
maintain this kind of stability without
to be the trust of the information and
the belief of the justice so that is
that is so fascinating and today I'm
sure you know that questions the
legitimacy of the power why you have to
maintain nation but not trust its own
people I don't not to let them charge
their feet so this is a constant a big
question and as they can never face it
face location and you can never answer
it
so for me I think this has to be a child
achieve this socata dependent our
judicial system so the society could
have a measurement about what is right
or wrong and not just according to a
party's well that is comforting
completely evo act and also i think the
freedom of expression which relate to
everybody and the freedom to get the
information and to communicate that's
absolutely necessary rights not just for
artists like me but for everybody so no
society can achieve any kinda greatness
without doing so